Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
Tenemos mucho en común
con nuestros primates más cercanos.
Pero en comparación, los humanos
parecemos... algo desnudos.
En lugar de un pelaje grueso
que cubra nuestros cuerpos,
la mayoría tenemos pelo
en nuestras cabezas
y en un otros pocos lugares.
¿Cómo es que estamos tan desnudos?
¿Por qué tenemos vello donde tenemos?
El vello humano y animal
están hecho de la misma cosa,
filamentos de proteína queratina
que crece de órganos llamados folículos,
que pasan por ciclos
de crecimiento y muda.
En los mamíferos, el vello
ha tenido numerrosos propósitos,
desde la suave pelusa
que cubre al conejo
a las rígidas púas
del puerco espín.
Pero para muchos mamíferos,
el vello crece en dos capas
que consisten de una capa
corta de vello básico
cubierto de otra
más larga protectora.
Juntos sirven para aislar
el cuerpo humano y proteger la piel.
El cabello humano, por otro lado,
es una combinación de estos dos.
Desafortunadamente,
los fósiles no conservan vello,
lo que dificulta a los investigadores
ubicar cuándo y cómo
nuestros ancestros perdieron su pelaje.
Pero los científicos
tienen algunas hipótesis.
Al parecer, hace millones
de años en África,
los primeros homínidos
bajaron de los árboles
y adoptaron un estilo
de vida más activo.
Mantenerse templado
se hizo más importante.
Con el tiempo, desarrollaron
más glándulas sudoríparas,
que les sirvieron para perder calor
evaporando la humedad por la piel.
Es más, los humanos tienen 10 veces
más de esas glándulas que los simios.
Pero perder bien calor sudando
es más difícil con pelaje.
Los científicos creen que los primeros
humanos perdieron pelaje en esta era
para que la sudoración
fuera más rápida.
Sin embargo, si perder vello
es tan ventajoso,
¿por qué todavía tenemos algo?
Al parecer hay usos únicos del vello
en distintas partes del cuerpo.
Cuando se trata de nuestras cabezas,
la regulación de temperatura
quizá juega una parte.
Desde que los primeros humanos
se aventuraron al aire libre
sus cabezas se habrían
expuesto al sol ardiente.
Cabello largo, creciente y grueso
protege nuestro cuero sensible
y evita que nuestros cerebros
se sobrecalienen.
El cabello oscuro rizado
protege mejor la piel contra el sol.
Otros tipos de cabello evolucionaron
según a donde iban los humanos.
En cuanto a las cejas,
los investigadores creen
que son útiles para la comunicación,
ya que están encima de
músculos faciales activos
que expresan sentimientos.
Se ha demostrado que las pestañas
minimizan el flujo de aire a los ojos
que evitan resequedad
y atrapar basura.
Y quizá el vello facial es útil
para identificar a lo lejos,
pero la verdad no sabemos.
La mejor evidencia es incipiente.
Por qué tenemos vello en
otra zonas es... más punzante.
Las axilas, los pezones, el pubis
están llenos de glándulas apocrinas.
Producen secreciones
grasosas y olorosas
que el vello grueso y rizado
que suele crecer en
estos lugares ayuda a dispersar.
Las secreciones emanadas de estas zonas
velludas pueden servir para identificar.
Por ejemplo, varios estudios muestran
que la gente puede identificar
el olor de sus axilas como
la de aquellos cercanos a ellos.
El tipo final de cabello humano
importante es el vello que nos cubre.
No sabemos si este vello
tiene algún propósito en sí,
pero los folículos capilares crecen de
bancos de células madres esenciales
que reparan piel dañada de una herida.
También son zonas importantes
de terminales nerviosas
que transmiten señales
de tacto suave al cerebro.
De hecho, aunque más fino,
los humanos casi tenemos
la misma densidad capilar
que simios de tamaño comparable.
No obstante toda esta charla
sobre la desnudez humana,
no estamos tan pelones
como nos vemos.